[Musik]
rambo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer neuen
episode main
wisst ihr was ich
hätte eigentlich einen großen plan für
die heutige folge allerdings werde ich
mich heute endlich mal um etwas anderes
kümmern der plan für heute war
eigentlich dass wir uns mit dieser
holzkohle generator fahr mal ein
bisschen auseinander setzen habe ich in
der letzten folge gefragt und das für
euch eher cheating ist oder noch klar
geht fast alle meinten dass hier das ist
halt kein schädling ist habe einfach ein
ganz normaler holz generator farben
gebaut allerdings kann es ein bisschen
spanisch vor dass das alles irgendwie
funktioniert und dass ich jetzt hier
einfach rein gucken kann hier kommt
holzkohle die lagert sich dann wiederum
hier in der kiste ich kann die nehmen
habe genügend kohle kann damit traden
mit level hoch gehen und so weiter und
so fort
eigentlich wollte ich mir damit ein
bisschen beschäftigen weil da ja ein
bisschen noch nicht so ganz funktioniert
da wurde mir auch tipps und in die
kommentare geschrieben ich habe
allerdings auch die tipps nicht
verstanden und dann wollte ich
eigentlich auch in die höhe gehen die
sich unter meiner hobbit höhle hier
befindet da können wir erst mal ganz
kurz vor allem auch mal eben unsere
kleinen luken hier wieder schließen der
mehr offen gemacht damit er ein bisschen
durchgelüftet wird ich glaube hier ist
mittlerweile kalt genug drin die sache
ist allerdings und das hat er zu beginn
der episode hier gerade schon gesehen
dass sich dort hinten ein doofer bähr
befindet
deswegen
und das werde ich wahrscheinlich auch in
den titel geschrieben haben wir wollen
wir uns heute endlich mal darum dass ich
meinen wald hier ein bisschen abfälle
das ist vor allem auch schon längst
überfällig weil hier immer so viele neue
monster spawnen die sache ist allerdings
dass wir aktuell keine reisen mehr haben
das heißt wir müssen so oder so noch mal
runter an unsere höhle hier vorne in der
wir auch generell noch gar nicht drin
waren
und wisst ihr was ich
glaube ich hätte gar nicht mit großer
vorbereitung da jetzt vorgehen sondern
mich einfach runter bewegen
irgendwie
sind die ganzen monster die wir hier
gesehen haben
die ganzen endermann et cetera sind
irgendwie weg ich bin allerdings auch
ganz ehrlich freunde ich will heute
keine große action ich möchte mich
einfach nur darauf konzentrieren hier so
ein bisschen eisen abzubauen vielleicht
auch das ein oder andere andere erz
mitzunehmen zum beispiel kupfer haben
wir hier vorne schon gesehen das wird
mir auch in die kommentare geschrieben
paar tipps was ich mit kupfer alles
anstellen kann mal schauen ob wir
überhaupt zu kommen in diesem projekt
allerdings
um einen konter habe ich mich gerade
joggen
ich wollte sagen euch erstmal eine ganz
fix it times wie ich mir hier nur kurz
ein bisschen eisen einsammeln
[Musik]
ach so ich
bin gerade
wieder an dem ort wo wir das schon heute
entdeckt haben
die ganzen höhlen unter unserem dorf
sind miteinander verbunden da hätte ich
auch ehrlich gesagt selbst drauf kommen
können da wurde mir auch damals in die
kommentare geschrieben den flughafen
auch sein dass du hier irgendwie ein
buch vergessen hast nie habe ich nicht
habe ich alles schon abgesucht meiner
test welt die sache ist dass das buch
glaube ich wirklich weg ist und da muss
man wirklich verraten dass für kakteen
haben damit wir uns noch mal ganz genau
angucken können was das denn da es für
monster waren allerdings werde ich mich
jetzt erst mal wieder hier ganz kurz
darauf konzentrieren dass ich mir hier
vorne noch das eisen leben mitnehmen und
dann auch hier vorne kurz wieder alles
zu bauen so dass sich auch hier ganz
kurz mal wieder hoch gehen kann und ob
wir das also noch eben mitnehmen kann
und dann bauen wir selbstverständlich
auch dass sie kurz eben wieder zu so
dass wir uns nun entspannt nach oben
bewegen können ionen ich habe fast 1
päckchen abgebaut das werden wir schnell
in unseren schmelzofen packen und
während das hier vorne dann schnell zu
reisen wird gehen wir auch mal ganz fix
schlafen weil es draußen schon dunkel
geworden ist und dann mache ich mir aus
dem eisen
und wie fällen den kompletten wald also
23 eisen haben wir auf jeden fall schon
mal fertig das heißt dementsprechend
können wir damit hier rüber gehen zu
unserem crafting table das einfach mal
hier auf teilen und uns schon mal sieben
äxte machen sieht jetzt zwar ein
bisschen komisch aus der sicherung in
sieben aixtron habe die packe ich mal
ganz beiseite weil wir hier effizienter
und schärfe drei darauf haben die werde
ich dafür erst mal nicht benutzen
allerdings werden wir wirklich so viele
excel benötigen und ich möchte jetzt
hier wirklich so ein bisschen lichter
haben ihr seht schon hier das sieht ganz
gut aus wenn hier die sonne dann so
reinkommt und die sonne geht ja hier auf
und geht hier unter dass sie mit diesem
weg also wir müssen uns erstmal auf
dieser seite hier ein bisschen
konzentrieren deswegen würde ich sagen
verstanden einfach mal mit diesem bau
mir der ist komplett weg das ist halt
echt sogar mit dieser tritscher
modifikation der wir können die einfach
ganz easy abbauen ich höre
den zombie oder dass eine achse kaputt
gegangen ist ist auch egal wir machen
weiter hier vorne mit dem baum der ist
komplett weg wir gehen wir hier zu den
bauern hin jetzt ruckelt jetzt auch ab
und zu mir so ein bisschen einfach weil
das hier vorne natürlich immer so ein
bisschen auch die pc-leistung anspruch
sei dir diese ganzen bäume von jetzt auf
gleich einfach
so
ist schon krass
[Musik]
obwohl ich diese modifikation so richtig
auch noch nicht so ganz verstehe
euch wieder eine ganz kurze time selbst
wie ich das ja alles einsammeln abbau
neues eisen hohe blablabla
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren ich habe auch
gerade gesehen dass wir vorne das weizen
wieder ein bisschen gewachsen ist
pflanzt das natürlich direkt wieder nach
mit den samen hier vorne ist noch nicht
fertig gewachsen allerdings haben wir
jetzt hier schon mal 13 stück das heißt
mit diesen 13 weizen kann ich jetzt auch
mal ganz kurz die wieder zu unseren
kühen gehen und die so ein bisschen
fahren wir benötigen ja immer noch auf
dauer leider ein bisschen leder und
müssen die irgendwann auch im laufe des
projekts töten wieder genauso wie
minecraft mit luca staffel 1 so dass wir
einfach leder bekommen für item rahmen
frames et cetera also mal schauen dass
das hier ein bisschen vorangeht ich
werde mich jetzt allerdings erstmal
darauf konzentrieren dass ich mal gucken
wie viel neues eisen wir haben und auf
der schmelz berufen dass alles neu
fertig gestellt hat er ist durch die
haben 31 eisen ich habe hier die cooper
paaren rein getan und das rohgold dann
kann ich das hier alles mal eben ganz
kurze wieder einpacken beim mann und ich
nehme mir natürlich mein eisen um mir
direkt auch neue ängste zu machen wir
benötigen nämlich jetzt elf stück
tatsächlich nochmal die werde ich jetzt
nehmen um mich weiterhin daran zu setzen
hier vorne alles ein bisschen abzufüllen
ihr sieht auch schon hier das ist
deutlich lichter geworden der hier
[Musik]
ist noch nicht gerade doch jetzt noch
ein zweiter kennt kann mir den jetzt
noch mal ganz kurz eben weg machen dann
machen wir den hier noch weg den hier
vorne machen wir auch noch weg und hier
vorne dann auch noch diesen fetten ich
meine ich mag diese fetten bäume und mir
wurde auch in die kommentare geschrieben
luca mach mal ein baumhaus hätte ich
auch bock drauf könnte man mal schreiben
ob ihr das auch cool finden würde ich
weiß wir sind zwar gerade nicht im
dschungel sondern er in so einem winter
ähnlichen wald allerdings möchte ich
trotzdem so eine kleine
aussichtsplattform mal auf dauer hier
eben noch hin pflanzen doch nun werde
ich mich erstmal hier bisschen darum
kümmern denn hier haben wir ja auch noch
eine menge bäume unter denen sich immer
wieder monster tümmeln ich finde meine
inventar leisten sie kaut und gerade
auch wirklich sehr sehr wild aus weil er
nur extra drin sind einfach ich finde
auch und ich kann es verstehen wenn der
ein oder andere eventuell sagt mensch
ist es irgendwie scheiße im wald kaputt
ja kann ich nachvollziehen die sache ist
allerdings dass ich hier auf jeden fall
auch neue ding wie so geht es nicht
was muss ich denn
ok dann würde ich sagen
bleibt das ding hier einfach stehen
so ein bisschen als erinnerung dass
jemand wald war
und wie schön das aussieht wenn das
diese durchscheint
ich schwöre euch wenn man sich das so
anguckt dann wird man nicht denken dass
das minecraft ist finde ich was ich
sagen wollte war auf jeden fall dass ich
hier auf jeden fall demnächst nochmal
ein bisschen mehr bäume hin pflanzen
werde eichen et cetera pp mit street
view peking kennt die brocken hin
die sind doch alle gleich groß die bäume
maximum one hundred
ich weiß nicht ob das eine gute idee ist
aber könnte mir aber auch und in die
kommentare schreiben wird es vielleicht
sinn machen dass sich alle bäume um
diese großen bäume drumherum abfälle um
dann die großen bäume anzuzünden das
geht hier auch nicht
die händler
die hängen glaube ich alle zusammen die
bäume hier
perfekt ist ist die aktie auch noch
kaputt ich gehe jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal ganz kurz schlafen ich merke
auch dass minecraft rate total am
ruckeln ist und das ist alles irgendwie
nicht so ganz flüssig läuft weil ich so
viele bäume gefällt habe ich kann es
nicht verstehen wenn der ein oder andere
welche wissen abgefragt ist darüber dass
ich in den wald ein bisschen kaputt
mache aber wie bereits gesagt wenn ich
da auf jeden fall noch ein paar mehr
reichen wollen wir in pflanzen und dass
sie schon so schon mal deutlich besser
aus wir haben deutlich mehr platz die
mittlerweile zur verfügung außer dieser
bereich da kann ich irgendwie nichts mit
anfangen also ich glaube ich muss
wirklich die außen rum alle abfällen
beispielsweise ihn hier oder ihn hier
vorne oder so so dass sich dann platzt
habe bei den inneren bäumen so dass sich
die anzubieten
es ruckelt richtig bei mir nach
[Musik]
so
für mich
nicht so sicher gerade
und
der etwas fehlt denn ich bin ja ich
mache nur einen ganzen wald kaputter
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren ich würde
gerade mal items eingesammelt hier vorne
befindet sich nichts mehr in
irgendwelchen holz sachen steckern oder
setzlingen und hier vorne auch nicht
aber ich gerade fünf mal hergelaufen
gefühlt und habe alles mitgenommen da
hinten haben wir zwar immer noch nicht
das ist ein blog da ist der bär da
hinten der hat sich heute allerdings
nicht als aggressiv herausgestellt hier
vorne ist allerdings eine menge
baumaterial gefällt worden von mir ich
habe mir insgesamt glaube ich über 15
extra heute gemacht und das alles hier
bekommen die ganze kiste ist voll mit an
baumstämmen hier vorne habe ich mal auf
welche rein bam bam bam und diese teile
die bretter und so die pack ich einfach
mal hier vorne noch um eine holzkiste
rennen wir haben auf jeden fall dadurch
hier schon mal ein bisschen mehr für
sicherheit gesorgt um meine höhle herum
hier vorne tannenbaum setzlinge rein
hier vorne die bretter ein bisschen
stärker und hier vorne habe ich erde
drehen und dann kann ich das verrottete
fleisch ganz kurz hier vorne zum anderen
verrotteten fleisch packen ihr sieht
auch schon im inventar ich habe sieben
weizen denn hier vorne sind der
zwischenzeit ein bisschen was gewachsen
als die ganzen leute mit ja eingesammelt
habe deswegen können wir damit ganz kurz
mal wieder hier vorne hin zu den kühen
bamm bamm bamm bamm bamm bamm bamm und
hier vorne auch zack zack und das letzte
weizen dann können sie sich auch ein
bisschen weiter vermehren wir uns in der
nächsten folge dementsprechend ein
bisschen leder holen und das letzte was
ich für heute auf meiner to do liste
stehen habe ist bäume nachpflanzen
reden was ist aber sollte 364
meister ihr werdet euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich fragen luca warum hast du
bäume gefällt wenn du jetzt bäume
nachpflanzen ja kann ich nachvollziehen
die sache ist allerdings dass ich wie
vorhin ja bereits gesagt eichen
setzlinge pflanzen möchte und dafür
werde ich auch einiges an blumen
benötigen denn dann wird sich der eine
oder andere aus minecraft in lucka
staffel 1 eventuell noch daran erinnern
ich benötige diese blumen weil dann die
chance gesteigert wird das neben einem
neu gewachsenen baum ein
bienen nest erscheint und dieses bienen
es benötigen wir für die nächste episode
die kommt nämlich an heiligabend online
am 24 12 denn ich möchte dort einen
kleinen tannenbaum bauen und dann möchte
ich kerzen darauf setzt und für kerzen
braucht man honigwaben blablabla
deswegen pflanzt sich einfach ein paar
eichenbäume und hoffe dann
schlussendlich das irgendwo hier auch
ein bienen es zum vorschein kommt hier
vorne setzen beispielsweise noch einen
weiteren krieg panel
was nur der brs ruckelt hat auch krasse
ich merke das richtig ist es richtig um
flüssig egal meine lieben freunde ich
will an der stelle die heutige episode
minecraft mit luca dann allerdings auch
beenden ich setze sie vor einer ganz
kurzen bauern hin dann irgendwie hier
vorne noch kurz ein und hier vorne vor
den stall auch noch mal ganz kurz ein
mensch diese folge freute
ich kann wirklich nicht mehr reden ich
nehme seit 45 minuten auf habe eine
menge geschafft heute
aber wenn tot
wenn es euch gefallen hat lasten daumen
hoch und ein video der band main kanal
klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr gegen
episode nicht verpassen wollen wir sehen
uns an weihnachten wieder bei minecraft
mit luca oder sonst bei anderen videos
[Musik]